100 Berkeley County teachers turned out. Teachers say they don't feel safe.
This teacher's protest took the form of an in-car parade.
I'm terrified to go in my classroom. If he wants to open schools how about he provide teachers with hazard pay?
He can drop my dead body right here.
Los Angeles was the first major city to announce that its public schools wouldn't be reopening
for in-person instruction in the fall.
83 percent of LAUSD teachers agree with the union's recommendation that teachers and students
not physically return to schools in August.
How do you do six feet social distancing?
How do you do that in passing periods?
And districts all across the country have followed suit.
A coalition of parents in California are suing the state on the grounds
that poor and special needs children in particular have received inadequate instruction during the shutdown.
This is a disgrace, it is a failure, it is going to cause huge economic problems and emotional problems
and learning problems.
School districts around the country are weighing the needs of students against the danger
that in-person instruction could cause COVID-19 to spread within their communities and teachers unions
are understandably concerned about protecting the health of their members.
But in Los Angeles the teachers union is exploiting the COVID-19 crisis to prevent competition
from charter schools.
The United Teachers Los Angeles co-signed a document with nine other unions
and the Democratic Socialists of America calling for a moratorium on all new charter schools
and private voucher programs.
It's about protecting a monopoly from losing any students,
and the funding that goes along with those students.
Corey DeAngelis is the director of school choice at Reason Foundation, the nonprofit
that publishes Reason TV, he says that entrenched interests are trying to stop families
from exercising choice.
If you really care about students and their safety you should want more options for more students
to be able to spread out in different locations and this doesn't do that but what it does do
is it allows the teachers unions to block students from switching to their competition.
Families are flocking to charters in part because they were poorly served by district schools.
In the spring the United Teachers Los Angeles, which declined our interview request,
successfully pressured the district to limit their members to four hour work days
and to give them the choice of opting out of live video instruction.
In Chicago nearly half of district school elementary school teachers logged into the virtual learning system
less than three days a week one recent survey found that private or charter schools
were more than twice as likely to meet with students daily than teachers at district run schools,
and 20 percent more likely to introduce new content.
But in addition to the charter school moratorium, United Teachers Los Angeles has demanded
that before reopening can move forward
the district needs an additional 250
million dollars in overall funding
a federal bailout medicare for all a new
wealth tax a new millionaire's tax and
defunding of the police
normal wasn't working for us before the
union asserts
and we can't go back oregon and
pennsylvania have also cut off
additional funding for charter schools
deangelis points to comments from the
president of the state's association of
administrators in pennsylvania who
stated his intention to handicap virtual
charter schools
we don't even have to guess about why
this is happening we're seeing special
interest groups explicitly lobbying to
protect a monopoly
it's putting the system in front of the
needs of families
in the worst time possible in july
california froze school budgets in place
at the best of the state's largest
lobbyist the california teachers
association
meaning that schools experiencing
searches and enrollment
won't get additional funding and schools
hemorrhaging enrollment
won't lose money that's limiting the
extent to which the california charter
network
a plus schools can scale up it's already
increased enrollment by 5000 for 2021
but has had to wait list an additional
24 000
students because the state won't
increase its funding
we've believed all along in the mission
and vision
to provide a more tailored flexible
and adaptable education delivery system
to the needs of students recognizing
that every individual human being is
different
jeff rice who is the president of a plus
schools attributes surging demand to the
network's experience with virtual
instruction
we're seeing a significant increase in
parents
who under normal circumstances may not
choose our school
but they're turning to us because they
want to put their children in a school
that has proven track record
of providing successful learning in
those settings at south sutter charter
school
we believe that when parents choose
students succeed
the budget freeze is also impacting
south sutter charter school in
sacramento where shauna anderson works
as an education specialist
that benefits these brick and mortar
schools
that where the kids are just leaving in
droves
because that's not what they want and it
really penalizes
schools like ours because we have
all of these students that want to
enroll but we're not going to be able to
get funding for them
anderson who also runs a homeschooling
resource network called
unschool.school says that the
traditional schooling model is
increasingly outdated
and particularly ill-suited to virtual
learning
education really needs to change this
model of education where kids can choose
what they
want to learn and how they learn best in
a truly
personalized plan is really
the wave of the future and if we could
do it in a public setting
great but if not people are going to do
it privately
and deangelis has reported on a new
phenomenon called
pandemic pods in which groups of parents
are pooling their resources to hire
their own teachers
it's essentially the idea of the
one-room schoolhouse that we did
a long time ago in america and
throughout the rest of the world
that you essentially outsource the
process of homeschooling
he says the rise of the pods or micro
schools could
permanently change the way americans
think about schooling
although it's mostly upper middle class
families with the resources to fund
these arrangements
which has been the subject of criticism
in the washington post and new york
times
deangelis says that the solution to this
problem is to change the structure of
education finance
so that the money follows the child even
outside of traditional government
certified schools
it's true that more advantaged families
are more likely to be able to exercise
these pandemic pod
options but we should fund families
directly so others can
participate as well and so that we can
have more equity in the school system
if schools do not reopen the funding
should go to parents to send their
child to public private charter
religious or
home school of their choice the key word
being
choice president trump has called for
more choice as a response to shuttered
schools and senators tim scott and lamar
alexander introduced the school choice
now
act which would earmark covet stimulus
dollars for parents
to spend directly on education senator
rand paul introduced a bill that would
require states to give parents direct
access to federal education dollars to
spend on tuition
or homeschool materials states like
oklahoma
and south carolina have already begun to
redirect money earmarked for schools in
the emergency cares act directly to
parents to cover private school tuition
and colorado legislators are proposing
putting the money
right into the hands of parents but in
california the political power of the
union will likely prevent that
but deangelis says that the current
moment could be a turning point for
school choice regardless
people are really re-envisioning how
school funding should look
and i think they're waking up to this
idea and this reality that there's no
good reason to fund the system
instead of the students directly parents
are the best educators
they know their kids best and maybe they
don't want to do it so
yes be able to use that money to send
them to a private school
or to pay a private tutor if there's
ever a time to do it
it's right now like this is like we're
riding the wave and
and something has to change
you